the Treaty of Versailles is one of the
most famous treaties in human history
and is one with the mixed reputation
signed in the wake of the Anton's
victory over the German Empire it did
several things it limited the size of
the German army demilitarized the
Rhineland demanded huge amounts of
reparations and perhaps most importantly
forced Germany to relinquish these lands
and many people decried the Treaty of
Versailles being unreasonably harsh on
Germany now you should know this video
isn't going to talk about whether or not
Versailles caused World War two it is
however going to ask one question just
how harsh was the Treaty of Versailles
really well it the best way to figure
this out is to look at contemporary
treaties and those from just before
world will want to see what the norm was
now obviously World War one was a much
bloodier more brutal conflict than
Europe had seen before up until this
point and so that should be taken into
account so in the context of the rest of
the world war one peace treaties verse I
wasn't actually very harsh
austria-hungary vive the Treaty of San
Germain on lay in the Treaty of Trianon
was completely dismantled the Austrian
half of the Empire lost these
territories to his neighbors many of
whom were brand-new nations it was the
Hungarian half that had it the worst
though much like Versailles Trianon
limited the size of the Hungarian
military demanded war reparations and
also took territory Germany lost 8
percent of its total land and ten
percent of his total pre-war population
to the treaty whereas Hungary was
stripped of 70% of its lands and 65% of
its pre-war population so I think we can
safely say that Trianon was certainly
harsher of course comparing the site to
the other World War 1 treaties isn't too
useful since it was the same war in the
same victorious countries negotiating
them so what about Germany's previous
peace treaties how harsh were they in
comparison to the sigh and the first
that we'll look at is the Treaty of
brest-litovsk this was signed between
the victorious Central Powers led by
Germany in the newly formed Russian
Soviet Federative social Republic what
this did was formalized the defeat of
the Russian Empire and demonstrate were
Germany expected a defeated nation to
give up which was a lot the Russian
Empire was stripped of about 30 percent
of its population depending on whether
or not you count places like Finland
whom the Communist authorities had
relinquished claims on anyway in terms
of land for the amount stripped away
wasn't much in comparison to the massive
Russian Empire it was however the
densely populated heavily industrialized
regions that Russia was to lose it was
also ordered to pay about 6 billion
marks in compensation to Germany in
comparison the Treaty of Versailles
ordered Germany to pay 130 billion mark
so the Allies only really expected to
receive a third of that and in terms of
industrial losses Germany lost barely
any capacity of course this does ignore
the fact that the Rhineland the
industrial heartland of Germany were to
be occupied for 15 years
although 15 years is obviously better
than forever so in comparison to
brest-litovsk Versailles he seems much
more lenient so what about before the
First World War
what the most obvious treaty to look at
is the Treaty of Frankfurt which brought
to an end the 1870 franco-prussian war
famously this saw the annexation of
Alsace Lorraine by Germany with France
losing roughly four percent of its
population in two and a half percent of
its lands furthermore the French had to
pay five billion francs in reparations
about three years worth of government
income the figure that Versailles
demanded was about twenty years of
government income so to conclude just
how harsh was foresight comparatively
well frankly not very in fact it was
fairly run-of-the-mill in terms of its
demands nations that lost Wars were
expected to lose land and to pay
reparations although in Germany the loss
of lands largely included the loss of
Germans to what made Versailles so
difficult for the German people to
swallow was that it deprived them of
their pride however on the upside for
them the original French plans of
carving Germany up like austria-hungary
never happened so it wasn't as harsh as
it could have been I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
the thanks to my patreon supporters whom
you can see on screen now plus with an
extra special thanks to Danny Maloney
cool and Castleman party boy Co Rob
Waterhouse mo Aaron the white Michael
Reynolds Chris wicker Gustav Swan James
Bissonnette Ashwin Emperor Gareth
Turner David Silverman spinning three
plates Maggie packs Kowski Christian
check a Spencer Lightfoot Winston k-word
Anthony Beckett Kelly moneymaker
Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn Skye Chappell
and Ike